Chloe Chloe invited you it's [ __ ]
cordial this whole thing sucks the drama
continues for the Kardashians in a sneak
peak at the new season of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians it appears Jordan
woods might want to apologize to Khloe
Kardashian she wanted to write you a
handwritten if she wants to write me I
got your address family sever ties with
Kylie's BFS after she was accused of
kissing Chloe's ex Tristan Thompson no
no but don't you say you didn't do
something that you think did when you
both told me
you I personally don't watch it back
because I just fired you know what
happens and it it's just I think a
little too toxic for me to keep reliving
stuff like that so I didn't watch it and
it's just a part of our job that we kind
of have to do so we can't just pick and
choose what we want to show that's not
fair and so that's just what it is but
Jordan told e t--'s she was moving
forward after all that life moves on
money doesn't stop world doesn't stop
and hopefully everyone is just you know
but that's not all it seems Scott Disick
may have gotten himself into some
trouble what's going on
Cher the new season premieres September
8th everyone is so critical of their
live sites
[Applause]